what is a fractional factorial design a
fractional factorial design is a type of
experimental design used to analyze the
effects of several factors or variables
on a response variable what is the
difference to a full factorial design in
a full factorial design every possible
combination of factor levels is examined
conversely a fractional factorial design
strategically excludes certain
combinations this redu reduces the
number of experiments while still
capturing essential information about
the system's behavior let's take a look
at an example let's assume we want to
know what has an influence on the
frictional torque of a bearing the
frictional torque is then a response
variable possible factors could be
lubrication temperature and the bearing
material the lubrication could have the
factor levels or characteristics oil and
grease the temperature could have the
level low and high and the bearing
material steel and keramic in a full
factorial design we would now test all
possible combinations of factor levels
we would therefore test the effect of
lubrication with oil temperature low and
material Steel on the frictional torque
the effect of lubrication oil
temperature low and material caramic on
the frictional torque the effect of oil
high and steel on the frictional torque
and so on and so
forth this makes it possible not only to
find out whether the individual factors
have an effect on a frictional torque
but also to find out whether there are
so-called interaction effects between
the factors however the number of runs
required increases very quickly as the
number of factors increases therefore
let us now take a look at the fractional
factorial design the fractional
factorial design is used for screening
experimental designs I.E if you have
more than approximately four to six
factors of course reducing the number of
runs means reducing information in
fractional factorial designs the
resolution is reduced what is the
resolution the resolution is a measure
of how well a doe can distinguish
between different effects more precisely
the resolution indicates how much the
main effects and interaction effects are
confounded in a design but what are main
effects and interaction effects and what
does confounded mean in design of
experiments the term effect refers to
the impact that a certain factor or a
combination of factors has on the
response variable of an experiment
essentially they measure how much the
response variable changes when you
change the factors a main effect is now
the influence of a single Factor on the
response variable for example what
influence the lubrication of a bearing
has on the frictional torque interaction
effects occur when the effect of one
factor on the response variable depends
on the level of another factor for
example the effect of the lubricant on
the frictional torque could depend on
the temperature but what does that mean
let's say we have an average frictional
torque value of 102 Newton mm for the
bearings with oil and an average value
of 108 Newt mm for the bearings with
grease then we have a main effec of
lubrication of 6 Newton mm but now we
can break this down into high and low
temperatures at high temperature we
could get 98 for oil and 102 for grease
so the difference between oil and grease
is only 4 Newton mm at low temperature
we could get 104 and2 so a difference of
eight so the lubrication factor is
influenced by the temperature and we
have an interaction between lubrication
and temperature the interaction leads to
a difference of 2 Newton mm to the
original result we therefore have an
interaction effect of 2 new mm full
factorial designs take all interactions
into account in our bearing friction
example in addition to the lubricant and
temperature factors we also looked at
the interaction between lubricant and
temperature however as the number of
factors increases numberous interactions
rapidly emerge for example if we have
the five factors a b c d and e we get
the interaction between two factors
between three factors between four
factors and between all five factors now
of course the question is do we really
need all the interactions or can we
reduce the resolution and this is
exactly what the fractional factorial
design does in a fractional factorial
design interaction can be confounded
with other interactions or with main
effects or factors what does confounded
mean effects of different factors or the
effect of interaction of factors cannot
be separated from each other the extent
to which the number of runs can be
reduced at the expense of resolution is
shown in this table the resolution is
usually indicated by Roman numers EG 3 4
5 and so on and so forth here on a
diagonal we see the full factorial
designs we'll go through what
resolutions three four and five mean in
a moment for example if we have six
factors we need at least 64 runs for a
full factorial design if we choose a
fractional factorial design with a
resolution of six we need 32 runs with a
resolution of four we need 16 runs and
with a resolution of three we need only
eight runs but what does that mean and
how does does it work the full factorial
design is always used as the starting
point let's take a look at the example
with eight runs let's say we have the
factors a b and c with a full factorial
design we can now test whether factor a
b or c have an effect we can test
whether the interactions with two
factors have an effect and whether the
interaction with all three factors has
an effect if we now want to test not
just three factors with a runs but an
additional fourth Factor say Factor D
then we must drop the information from
one of the interactions for example the
interaction of a b and c if we want to
test a fifth factor with a trials let's
say Factor e then we will have to drop
another interaction for example the
interaction between B and C but I didn't
express myself correctly we are not
actually dropping the information we are
mixing the new factor with the
interaction we've confounded the factor
with the interaction what does that mean
it means that we are unable to determine
if an observed effect is attributable to
factor D or to the interaction of a b
and c similarily we can't distinguish if
an effect results from Factor e or from
the interaction of A and B of course it
is much less critical to mix one factor
with an interaction of three factors
then with an interaction of two factors
and now we have a good transition to the
resolution what do the resolutions 3
four and five mean at resolution three
main effects can be confounded with
interactions of two factors for example
Factor D with the interaction of the
factors A and B experiments with
resolution three should therefore be
considered as critical they can only be
used if the interaction of two factors
is significantly small smaller than the
effects of the main factors otherwise
the interaction of two factors can
significantly distort the result of one
factor experiments at resolution four
are much less critical here only the
main effects are confounded with the
interactions of the three factors and
the more factors are involved in an
interaction the smaller the effect is
likely to be furthermore in resolution
four interactions with two factors are
confounded with interactions with other
two factors experiments at resolution
five are not considered critical main
effects are only confounded with
interactions of four factors in the same
way two Factor interactions are only
confounded with interactions of three
factors but how do you confound a factor
and an interaction let's take a look at
this example here we have the full
factorial design of the three factors a
a b and c these eight runs are carried
out in total we still only consider
factors with two levels minus one stands
for one level and one for the other for
our frictional torque example the test
plan would then look like this for
example for the factor temperature minus
one is the low temperature and one is
the high temperature if we now run the
experiments we obtain a value for the
response variable for each run if the
factor a is one or minus one this has a
certain effect on the target value
exactly the same if the factor B is one
or minus one the interaction effect now
tells us whether there is an additional
effect if Factor A and B are
simultaneously one or minus one or if
both go in exactly opposite direction so
on one side we have the pairings with
the same sign and on the other side the
pairings with an unequal sign now we can
check whether there is a difference in a
response variable between the values in
the green group and the values in the
red group if yes then there is an
interaction between A and B however if
we know in advance that there is only a
very small interaction if any then we
can use these combinations to test a
fourth Factor D to do this we simply
multiply A and B now we always have a
one if the factors a and B have the same
sign and minus one if they have a
different sign now of course a problem
may arise when analyzing the results if
there is a difference between the green
and the red values in the response
variable we cannot say whether this
effect comes from the interaction
between a and b or whether the effect
comes from the factor D if we are
already sure that there can be no
interaction between A and B this is of
course not a problem then we can be sure
that the difference is due to factor D
in the same way we can now take the
interaction of a and c and also measure
Factor e and the interaction of A and B
and C and measure factor F therefore in
this case we measure six factors with
only eight runs but we can no longer
distinguish the factor D from the
interaction A and B we can no longer
distinguish the factor E from the
interaction A and C and we can no longer
distinguish factor F from the
interaction a b and c and now I'll show
you how you can create a fractional
factorial design online with data tab to
do this simply go to data.net click on
plus and then on doe here you can select
which design you would like to create eg
a full factorial design or a fractional
factorial design so let's click on
fractional factorial design next you can
determine the number of factors and the
number of runs let's just take four
factors and eight runs so we have a
resolution of four here can now enter
the names of the factors and Define the
factor levels let's say temperature with
low and high lubrication with oil and
grease material with steel and keramic
and speed with low and high you will
then be shown the test plan and can
export it
now you can carry out the
test afterwards you can copy all the
data back to data
Tab and evaluate the
results I hope you enjoyed the video see
you
soon